um a really famous sniper Chris Kyle
right we had we we actually do a thing
down here in Florida every year called
sniper craft sniper craft is put on
through a company called SRT supply and
we would bring in about eighty snipers
from around the area someone come in
from out of the state but most time
we're here locally yeah and we always
bring in a guest speaker Chris Kyle at
the time happened to be one of our guest
speakers that had come in to talk he was
still active mhm
he was an active military was act still
he was still on the teams right and came
to our method to have some photos with
him get some take some photos chance
he's like hand guys I'm still active we
can't do that right now oh really so
yeah so he was real real a super great
guy yeah we work with another group
called Black Dagger out of SOCOM black
hat Black Dagger military Hunt Club and
Chris would come out and basically what
this is this is taking combat vets or
vets period who have some sort of
catastrophic injury and bringing them
out either hunt or to shoot guns we've
got a former Green Beret romy he he's
over LinkedIn he had gotten shot through
the neck in Iraq and the guys that when
he got shot they didn't realize been
shot through the neck yanked him back
inside the vehicle well it paralyzed him
from the neck down now this guy is a
green beret did more than most of us by
5:00 a.m. in the morning everyday we're
just getting up and starting our day and
some of us were waiting till 8 o'clock
to started but he decided that he's
gonna be a green beret for his whole
wife married a beautiful woman after he
became paralyzed
I obviously depression set in he's in a
full wheelchair of the emus with the
head up with his neck in his mouth and
he decided he wanted to come out one day
and come out with us out to the range
and we had a guy that was out there the
same day who was kind of in the same
situation who had a wheelchair that he
could actually mount a rifle on and
shoot from by blowing into a straw whoa
and so we looked at getting this for
Romi and bringing this on board so now
he's shooting again we're shooting
antenna right which is an explosive that
blows up when you shoot it so we will
have those out to 15 100 yards he's
actually shooting them again so just
like a green beret should be yeah and so
we work this other side of it through
so calm and the guys over there at
MacDill a Dave winters puts this event
on it's a great event working with also
gold star parents parents who have lost
children shouldn't call them children
they've lost adult children or their
kids in combat in the commode MacDill we
need to bring them out shooting each of
the parent where's a picture of their
son or their daughter on their on their
shirt and we just make sure we ask about
them as we as we go throughout the day
with them right wow that's amazing so
yeah it's so farming the journey has
been fantastic and I've also read about
MDMA being a big you know an effective
treatment for PTSD it's funny say that